let me tell you something right now -
you know when Korea beat Germany I was
really happy for Korea because we got to
help another brown nation get through -
to the last 16 we really helped them and
what happened was if you don't know if
you're not following the World Cup
Mexico lost to Sweden so they were out
of the World Cup and Korea had to beat
Germany which was never gonna happen
because Germany are the champions
powerhouse right but what did we do we
went 2-0 it was a miracle like a Disney
movie right it's just about honor at
that point and then Mexicans what Mexico
you know what the Mexicans did he
honored us oh great you know what they
did they picked us up yeah and they
[ __ ] ran around with us on their
shoulders around town saying thank you
thank you you know and in New Mexico
City you know they went to the embassy
and they'd the chancellor or whatever's
Korean Chancellor they brought him out
they did shots of tequila with them and
they picked him up like it was a [ __ ]
puppet you know there was something yeah
I think what but that that random Korean
guy yeah who everyone wanted to take a
picture with yeah he just allowed people
to like basically like idolize him oh I
would it was it was like receiving all
the love with like yeah I did like I
said he did something goalkeeper no no
some random guy in Mexico Korean dude
just was getting taking selfies with
people because people were like what cuz
he was Korean that's you know what I
would have done hold my dick out suck oh
my suck it we would suck it off you
really wanted the last 16 that's what I
did
suck it so you know we I was I'll be
honest with you I was caught up on the
heat I was caught on the end the hypen
yeah
and all that I was so happy for Mexicans
I was so happy for Korea it was it just
felt you know what the World Cup is
supposed to be it connects people but
then I saw this [ __ ] yeah no there's
hundreds of photos by the defendant its
Mexicans doing Chinese eye things into a
camera white they not Korean I things
what why'd you say - why did you
specifically say Chinese because look at
the way they're being they're backwards
directly back Chinese yeah yeah oh yeah
this yeah they're up a little up but so
I posted this photo on Instagram and
there was a pretty and I don't want to I
don't want to give up so this it's a
photo of a bunch of Mexican fans of
their team in their jerseys and they're
doing Chinese eyes and then because I
wanted to see what the comments would be
and Nick Youssef probably trumped
everyone else that what he said did you
take this photo from stage very funny
that's good right one of other guy goes
which one is you which is a very funny
one that's good
but there was um a lot of Asians mad and
there's a comedian named PK I want to
read his comment and this is the tone of
a lot of Koreans okay I glad you posted
these he doesn't have it no he doesn't
want me to be very American I know but
what can I do okay fine this is P can I
just make inner
his inner Asians coming up yeah your
Portuguese how rooting for Mexico I just
saw the Mexican yeah my turn Mexican oh
wow all right no I'm gonna sort of a try
your best yeah I gradual I got your
Portuguese okay are you rooting for
Mexico because more Mexican showing
career love after we help them events I
love all Mexican except these [ __ ]
doing slang high and trying to pass it
off like no big deal gtfo
H
what does that mean yeah that's exactly
let me say that again
the most the most unoriginal she people
have been making for Asian for so some
say wave for century are you saying
cholo come up with something no [ __ ]
idiots that's the sentiment yeah hey can
I say you know what my opinion is at the
end of the day it's funny yeah I don't
care at the end of the day it's a small
tiny minority of people doing that so I
think that it's actually kind of you
post what you want to post but there's
already so much like division in this
country and some idea it's like we keep
pointing out differences and things that
like hurt our feelings we never kind of
reach out and see the humanity of it for
starters yeah they should come up with
something more original that's dumb but
that doesn't speak for the you know from
any of the Mexicans I know like they
would never do that
I guarantee you that wasn't in LA yeah
that was in Mexico know anybody who
would do that that's like a total of
let's say even if it was 90 people 90
dumb [ __ ] wouldn't speak for them but
no it wasn't just not even first of all
a couple of TV Telemundo I heard about
yeah they got fart or like I'm suspended
yeah they did that too on air on air so
what I'm saying it's not just 20 people
it's hundreds of I've seen hundreds of
photos of that and I'm going to just
just tell you it's weird it's like holy
[ __ ] they saved us it's weird do you do
in there I like that it's also like is
that a thank you 1997 yeah because I
kind of tokenized the idea of like the
Asian person it's like it's still you're
still at unique though you know you're
still at Chino you're not really like
from from like I think all my Asian
friends are called Chino at some point
at one point in another yeah like that's
all you are really yeah Isaac Ben C used
to call me coochie know I could she
knows different that means nasty like
dirty like a pig yeah I know but I'm
Korean Korean and I Machino so they
would say Cochinos I was like two things
yeah that's why I never got that oh it's
got Buddha's delight what what always
call me Buddha's delight Legolas in
Georgia like there's a restaurant called
Buddha's the hall that's why yeah that's
bad so yeah but what I'm saying is even
though that's [ __ ] up you posting it
makes the sentiment like feel stronger
and I can feel like it like at this
point in time like can we just look for
more things we have in common versus
things that are gonna piss oh so what I
did was wrong no no no I'm not saying
it's wrong it needs to be to get
organized that Sarah Silverman liked it
Silverman doesn't like any of my [ __ ] is
the first pose that's the first post she
light generally Koreans and Mexican I'm
gonna realize all the topic I'm gonna
read off all the cop I'm gonna just show
you who liked the photo in terms of
comedians okay
he doesn't matter he doesn't matter
doesn't matter
he doesn't matter Theo von that matters
Michael Rosenbaum that matters
he doesn't matter what happened in this
Sarah Silverman
what's going on is it because I said
here like that
no I this is how I sweat every day of my
life just because we sold out basically
thank you yeah thanks everybody for
selling I'm buying our t-shirts that's
great
are you gonna love it it's great fabric
it's made out of wool skin absolutely
it's not a wolf it's a little wool for
what Wolf's again none of zarnov it's
synthetic wolf skin
[Music]